hey all right
thank you jc our own i know i know but
it's okay we don't need the open because
we have nene bubby in the flesh okay our
own cooking confidence coach nanny bubby
is back in studio
and thanks to chapman automotive for
sponsoring this segment we are ready to
whip up marinated fontina cheese and
grapes on rosemary skewers you see these
how are you and i smell it already oh
i'm so glad to be here with you oh my
gosh i missed you we've missed you i
have missed you back like i said i've
missed being able to try and we're going
to do that today we're going to check it
out today so last year i've done a lot
of confidence coaching with people who
want to learn to cook and whether you're
an experienced cook or just starting out
in your cooking journey everybody wants
the same thing where is there an
appetizer or what is an appetizer that
can be an all-time standby so we're
going to make one today without having
to do too much well or if you practice
enough it becomes easier and easier so
in your cooking journey where are you
are you novice beginner or you're well
ingrained and on the beginner side of
things okay fine well then i i need the
cooking cup okay so then let's let's
coach it right through it are you ready
yes i'm ready let's do it so we're going
to start with fontina cheese and we're
going to cut it in cubes as you can see
right here cut in cubes or maybe over
here and
sometimes you would want to marinate in
a plastic bowl if you have one but if
you don't i prefer
to actually marinate in a ziploc bag
because you're going to put it in the
refrigerator for overnight so if you
will start put in about three quarters
of this teaspoon sorry of chili pepper
chili pepper okay
there you go
a little bit i'll pop it right in here
yep and then a half cup of that rosemary
which is it i think that's a half cup so
you can pour it right in the interest of
the time that's about a half a cup oh my
gosh look at that
okay and then you're going to take the
salt and put about oh a teaspoon of salt
in there
i can do that yes you can i can do that
there we go and so i'm going to add the
oils but before i do i'm going to tell
you where the rosemary came from so
these are rosemary skewers that came
right out of the garden right just like
right here just like right here and what
we did is we took the leaves we pulled
them right off you see how i did that
onto a cutting board and i chopped them
up and that was the little diced
rosemary that you put in here so we've
got one we've got
two
and this is the fun part for the kids to
do you know yes it is it is because you
should always be cooking with your
children because
it is a good deed to teach your children
how to feed themselves right to talk to
my mom about that yeah
so in the interest of time i have taken
this so just just real quickly we're
going to add two tablespoons of olive
yep of lemon-flavored olive oil which
that's about it and two tablespoons of
fresh apple
white balsamic vinegar i've never heard
of that i know i know it's amazing there
we go right in and then you're gonna
ziplock it you're going to massage it
yes you got to get it all together
and that's why a ziploc bag is so much
better than putting it into the
container because it you can turn it
around and light so we're going to zip
it up and then i'm going to show you
very very quickly
how to let's see we start with a grape
are you ready yes i am okay so i'm going
to do the ingredients are on the screen
by the way yes so you want to always
hold it tight so that you don't break
the olive and then we'll reach in here
and we will grab the cheese this is the
marinated fontina cheese hold it very
tight you can see on all four ends so it
doesn't break as you skewer it
just push it right on there you go
and then we're going to grab oh there it
is one more whoop a grape i got confused
even nanny bubby gets confused okay
all right all right we've got one more
minute to show this off you got it so
we're going to take this we're going to
put it right here okay so watch this
plate watch how gorgeous
together yeah i love this all right
so we're going to go one
two
three
four
five this is where you can get depending
on yes because watch how we end this
okay i'm excited yep there we go we'll
push this away so you can
grab me while i grab a piece oh i love
that you're doing that you don't know
how happy that makes me
so this recipe came from somebody in our
gather with nanny bubbe facebook group
roseanne who is a viewer found me from
here and then joined our facebook group
then we're going to take this right here
okay and we are going to plop that right
in the middle
maybe mound it up just a tiny bit more
and then my darling reach in and have
yourself a party wow right
beautiful
whether you're experienced you make it
look like everyone says oh you're so
creative and if you're just starting out
everybody says you're amazing how did
you learn to do that i love that okay on
the count of three spread love like
butter all right check out nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media and
online
at nannybubby.com so i've got cheese in
my mouth but we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment we'll be right back